let's talk about how to detoxify your
lungs what is the best way okay we're
talking about detoxifying pollution that
chemicals from smoking and by the way
since you probably already know this but
there's 7 000 chemicals in cigarette
smoke at 250 are harmful and 69 are
actually are carcinogenic I mean there's
even a radioactive element in smoking
you have ammonia you have formaldehyde
hydrogen cyanide and even cadmium which
is a heavy metal and you have firsthand
smoking and then you have secondhand
smoking right but there's also third
hand smoking all the chemical particles
that end up like on furniture clothing
that you come in contact with as well
and of course the goal of you probably
watching this is to reduce your risk of
cancer and things like that but there's
another big problem that is associated
with smoking
and that is COPD chronic obstructive
pulmonary
disease 12 million people in the United
States have COPD so I'm going to share
some information on how to prevent that
and if you have it what to do to improve
it but smoking is not the only issue
here you have pollution in the air you
have Cleaning Supply chemicals you have
mold and mildew in your house you even
have something called radon gas that can
actually affect your lungs and then also
if we
compound that with pre-existing
infections to the lung it can lead to
some major problems and just so you know
like lung cancer doesn't always come
from smoking it can be referred or they
called spread from other organs and so
if your lung has inflammation in it okay
it becomes a target for cancer
because cancer tends to spread in areas
of inflammation so the key thing with
this video is all about inflammation in
the lung and how to reduce it because
anytime you have inflammation you then
get Scar Tissue fibrosis and then it
gets to a point where it becomes
irreversible so when a toxin comes in
contact with your lung tissue it
irritates it it's going to start
creating inflammation and then over time
if there's a chronic exposure to that
toxin you start developing fibrosis and
you also at the same time get a lowered
amount of your own
antioxidants that are there to protect
the lung so you have this insult or free
radical damage situation and the
lowering of the protective mechanism of
your own body's antioxidants goes down
but what a lot of people don't realize
is that these chemicals that go into the
lung
go systemic they don't stop at the lung
and a lot of them end up in the liver so
the liver is at the heart of the
detoxification system so it's going to
take those poisons that are in
cigarettes or pollution and it's going
to dismantle them hopefully and it does
this through a series of
enzyme interactions called phase one
phase two phase three detoxification
enzymes but it gets to a point where it
becomes overloaded where the liver
cannot keep up with this especially if
it's a chronic exposure to these
chemicals the liver starts to develop
inflammation it can even develop fat
from inflammation as you filled up the
lungs with chemicals and pollution it
can end up in the arteries and create a
lot of heart problems but I think the
key note here is chronic exposure okay
chronic exposure not exposure here and
there that your liver can easily deal
with this but it's just a routine
chronic exposure over a long period of
time that's where we have a problem
let's jump right into what to do about
it there's some really interesting data
on probably one of the best
uh protective remedies for your lung as
well as the liver and it's very
different than what you're going to find
when you do searches on detoxifying your
lungs because normally they're going to
talk about
you know herbs that help you stop
coughing might decrease swelling but
this other herb that I'm going to
mention is probably the most potent not
just because what it can do for your
lung but what it can do for your liver
and that herb is milk thistle milk
thistle is one of the best antidotes to
poison so if you poison yourself from
either a snake bite or a poisonous
mushroom or toxins or you're just taking
medications you should be taking milk
thistle to protect the liver well just
so happens that that same protection
occurs in your lungs as well so if you
have COPD or you're a smoker or you're
trying to repair your lungs milk thistle
is what you want to start taking because
milk thistle is one of the best
anti-inflammatories it's the best
protector against toxins and it's a
really good remedy if you have COPD and
also any type of liver problem number
two tocotranols this is a type of
vitamin E that's like 50 times stronger
than your regular vitamin E called the
tocopherols so tocatrinals are all about
getting rid of free radical damage it's
a very powerful antioxidant it's a very
powerful anti-inflammatory and it's
especially good to prevent fibrosis so
that stage where you go from
inflammation to scar tissue there's a
lot of data that talks about tocotrino
helping prevent scar tissue in your
arteries and then the liver
but also in your lungs so tocatrinals
are a number two remedy especially to
reduce inflammation and number three
vitamin D you want to take this probably
in 20 000 IUS but vitamin D is a very
powerful anti-inflammatory and it's
really good for COPD
any type of lung inflammation as well as
any autoimmune diseases now there are
some interesting links between COPD and
autoimmune you may have antibodies
against your own lung tissue if you have
COPD and this is something you'd have to
have tested but I want to bring it up
because it is an issue and if you have
antibodies that are creating this
inflammation in your lungs this goes
beyond just being exposed to toxins this
is that your immune system that's
misidentifying your lungs as a pathogen
vitamin D is going to be very important
and this additional remedy so if you
have antibodies against your own lung
tissue I'm going to recommend a product
from another company that I'm not
affiliated with it's called standard
process and the product is called
pneumotrophin PMG you just take one of
those before bed and that can
potentially act as a decoy
so these antibodies can then attack it
and not your lungs giving your lungs a
chance to heal and regenerate now since
we're on the topic of good herbs to
prevent inflammation I think it would
probably be appropriate to learn a
little bit more about this milk thistle
and for that you should check this video
right here